The Punisher may have made his debut
over on daredevil and both shows share
the character Karen page but Marvel's
long-awaited Punisher series is all
Castle The Punisher finds himself in the
middle of a government conspiracy that
ties back to his time running black ops
overseas now Castle has a chance for
vengeance bloody bone breaking vengeance
but when the screen finally fades to
black what actually happened here's a
recap of the ending of The Punisher and
what it all means
warning spoilers and grunting ahead
quest for vengeance the series opens
with castle tracking down the rest of
the folks he thought were involved with
his family's murder only to eventually
learn the web of betrayal goes even
higher than he'd suspected he starts
working with David Lieberman aka micro
to unravel the conspiracy and the
mission eventually sees them cross paths
with homeland security agent Dina Madani
who's investigating an operation from
castles tenure on the illegal black ops
squad through a very tenuous alliance
they finally realize shady intelligence
official William Rollins is really
pulling the strings
Rollins managed castles black ops team
and is trying to clean up the mess and
any lingering evidence by any means
necessary
with a new target for revenge Castle
spends much of the series tracking
Rollins finally breaking free after
being captured and beating him to a
bloody pulp this is the man who pulled
the strings to have Frank's family shot
so let's just say Rollins comeuppance is
as brutal as it is richly deserved a new
life for a show that spent so much time
with flying bullets and bloodied fists
it ends on a surprisingly quiet moment
after spending the past few years on the
run in hiding Frank can finally live a
life in public if he chooses he seems to
be coming to grips with that realization
in the show's final scene as Frank
attends one of the veterans support
group meetings led by his pal Curtis
Castle talks about what it's like being
a soldier without a mission though that
obviously works in a broad sense he's
talking to a room of veterans after all
Castle is also referring to the fact
that his quest for vengeance is over
he's free and not knowing what comes
next is the scariest thing of all jigsaw
the biggest surprise in the show's final
episode was the Punishers decision to
actually let Billy Russo live following
their fight at the Carousel instead of
finishing him off Castle decided to drag
his face across a broke
mirror taking away Russo's own identity
his looks and his charm God made me this
way for a reason
it could be wrong not to share the
wealth for comics fans that didn't come
as a surprise they already know Russo as
The Punisher villain jigsaw he was a mob
hitman in the comics disfigured after
the Punisher tosses him through a window
while they don't have as much of a
connected back story in the comics
making them soldiers in the same unit
served as a way to make a tangible
connection between their origins on TV
series showrunner Steve Lightfoot has
teased they're only halfway through with
Russo story and if he returns he'll be a
totally different guy The Punisher works
best when the mission is personal and
this could certainly fit the bill micros
happy ending
castles partner Lieberman spent the
better part of a year hiding out in an
industrial basement after faking his
death only able to see his family via
the surveillance cameras he placed
before he left he's been forced to watch
his loved ones move on without him but
his micro and Punishers mission draws
closer to its end Lieberman is able to
reconnect with his family and finally
reveal himself it's an awkward but
heartfelt reunion by the time the series
wraps they seem to be headed for some
form of protective custody in the wake
of the epic conspiracy that unraveled in
season 1 if nothing else at least
somebody got a happy ending Madani
survives though Castle meets out justice
as well as anyone he did require a bit
of help from the other side specifically
through an uneasy alliance with homeland
security agent Madani who initially
needed castle to testify to bring down
the blackops conspiracy she protected
castle when Russo shot him in the
stairwell and once again saved his life
by taking castle to her parents house
for medical care as opposed to a
hospital where he would have been
arrested or worse Madani tracked castle
and Russo to their final showdown at the
Carousel and though she was shot by roof
so she gave castle the opportunity to
get the drop on Russo and win the fight
Castle got Madani medical attention and
she repaid his kindness by helping cut
the deal for him to get a new identity
and go free as the season ends she still
has her job and looks to likely move up
the Homeland Security ranks after
exposing the conspiracy what's next more
than any other Marvel show on Netflix
the first season of Punisher truly felt
self-contained using its 13 episodes to
pick up the final threads of castles
quest for revenge and put a period at
the end of that story it even ended with
Castle
unsure of what comes next he doesn't
have a mission but that doesn't mean he
can't find one if Netflix wants a second
season as of the making of this video
Lightfoot says he hasn't heard anything
about a potential second season but
considering every other Marvel show has
scored a renewal the odds are decent
will see Baron Thal sport his trademark
skull armor again and Billy Russo may be
back as well
Lightfoot told Entertainment Weekly I
felt like we gave Billy a great
trajectory of his own which were now
only half way through if we come back to
him he's going to be a totally different
guy if and when the renewal order comes
viewers should brace themselves for the
formal introduction of jigsaw thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]